NOW COME TO ORDER GOOD EVENING
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES
WE MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS IN IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING. AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS. SENATE IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. OUR MEMBERS ATTENDING
REMOTELY TODAY ARE SENATOR SPACE
AND SENATOR BRADFORD. WE'RE ALSO
LIVE STREAMING THE HEARING TODAY
SO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC MEMBERS
AND STAFF MAY FOLLOW ALONG FROM
A DISTANCE. SENATORS BATES IN
BRADFORD AS A REMINDER PLEASE
MUTE YOUR PHONES FOR YOUR
COMPUTERS. THIS WILL GREATLY AID
THE ELIMINATION OF ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I GUESS THAT EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED
TO EASE THE RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE IN YOUR
PROGRAMAR. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK UP UP WHEN
HERE ASKING BY TWO. POLICE
SELECTOR MUTE BEFORE BEGIN
SPEAKING. R. I. T. WILL PUT YOU
BACK MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE.
ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE
MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN AND STATE YOUR NAME. HE
WILL THEN BE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. AS A REMINDER TO
EVERYONE OUT THERE TODAY'S
HEARING CONSISTS ONLY OF ITEMS.
THAT ARE ON THE SUSPENSE FILE.
ALL THESE MEASURES HAVE ALREADY
HAD A HEARING BY THIS COMMITTEE.
WITH TH OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
A LOT OF FOLKS FORGET THAT
ASPECT OF THINGS. ALL OF THESE
MEASURES HAVE HAD THEIR HEARING
AND HAD PUBLIC TESTIMONY OR THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. AS NOTED IN THE DAILY
FILE THE SUSPENSE FILE HEARING
IS A VOTE ONLY HEARING WITH NO
TESTIMONY. I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK- COMMITTEE MEMBERS STAFF-
MY STAFF THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE- COMMITTEE
PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE STAFFER
ALL OF THEIR ASSISTANCE AND WORK
ON THESE IMPORTANT MEASURES.
BEFORE WE BEGIN. I'D LIKE TO
MAKE A- BRIEF ENOUGH TROUBLE PRE
FINANCE MYTHS ABOUT HOW WE
PROCEED. TO THAT MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC MEMBERS AND STAFF CAN
FOLLOW ALONG. WE WILL BE MOVING
QUICKLY THROUGH THE AGENDA
PROPHETICALLY IN THE AUTHOR'S
NAME. PLAY CLOSE ATTENTION AS WE
WILL ONLY BE ADDRESSING MEASURES
THAT. PROVOKED THIS MORNING. IF
YOU DON'T HEAR ME TAKE UP A
PARTICULAR MEASURE THAT BILL IS
HELD UNDER SUBMISSION. I WILL
ANNOUNCE THE AUTHOR THE MEASURE
NUMBER AND PROVIDE A BRIEF
DESCRIPTION OF ANY AMENDMENTS TO
THE MEASURE BEFORE WE TAKE THE
VOTE. FOLLOWING THE HEARING WE
WILL BE POSTING THE HEARING
RESULTS IN THE ACTIONS TAKEN ON
EACH MEASURE ON THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AT W. W. W. DOT S. A.
P. R. DOT SENATE DOT CA DOT GOV.
AGAIN WEBSITE IS W. W. W. DOT S.
A. P. R. DOT SENATE DOT CA DOT
GOV. IN ADDITION FOR ANY BILLS
THAT ARE BEING AMENDED TODAY WE
WILL BE HOSTING. AN ADDENDUM
ANALYSIS- WITCHING A SOME OF THE
M. AND THE REVISED FISCAL
IMPACTS OF THE AMENDED BILL. NOW
IT'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR PORTANTINO I'M HERE
PORTANTINO HERE SENATOR BATES
HERE. SENATOR BRADFORD BATES
RIGHT TO PRESENT BATES HERE
BRADFORD PRESENT- PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY US SENATOR JONES. JONES
HERE CENTER KAMLAGER HERE IN
ORDER HERE SENATE EARLIER HERE
LAYERED HERE SENATOR MURKOWSKI
CASKEY HERE WE HAVE FIVE MEMBERS
PRESENT IN THE ROOM WE HAVE FIVE
MEMBERS HERE SO WE HAVE A
QUORUM. WE WILL BE GOING TO THE
FIRST ITEM- SENATOR ALAN WE HAVE
SB FIVE SEVEN NINE THE MOTION
DETECTION MEDIUM THE- IT'S ON
SCHOOL FINANCE. THE MOTION IT
WHEN MADE WILL BE TO AMEND THE
BILL FOR AUTHOR TO PROVIDE A
HOLD HARMLESS PROTECTION FOR
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN THE CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR. IT'S SB FIVE SEVEN
NINE ALLEN IS OUR MOTION. SOME
OF. HAVE A MOTOR BY MISTER WHITE
CAPS. MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SENATE BILL FIVE SEVEN
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
SENATOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE BATES. YOUR BATES
FOR SB FIVE SEVENTY NINE HI.
REBATES BY CENTER BRADFORD
BRADFORD ON SB FIVE SEVENTY NINE
OUR BRADFORD FIVE CENTERS JONES
JONES I CENTER KAMLAGER. HI
KAMLAGER EYES CENTER LAYERED ON
A LAYER OF ICE AND- WHAT KASKY
HI CASKEY I BILL HAS SEVEN LOADS
FABULOUS OUT WITH SEVEN VOTES
ARE NEXT BILL IS SENATOR ALLEN
SB SIX TWENTY ON DISTILLED
SPIRITS. IT WILL THERE ARE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO MODIFY THE
AMOUNT OF DISTILLED SPIRITS
PERMIT HOLDERS CAN SHIP TO
RESIDENTS REQUIRE OUT OF STATE
BEER MANUFACTURERS TO COMPLY
WITH THE STATE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING PROGRAM AND
CLARIFY THE DISTILLED SPIRITS
CAN BE. DELIVERED BY COMMON
CARRIERS AND THEY'RE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO AMEND THE LIMIT
THE OVERALL AMOUNT CERTAIN
DISTILLERS CAN SHIP PER YEAR.
OUR MOTION. ON A MOTION BY
MISTER WHITE CAL SKI- WE HAVE A
COMMENT BY MISS TOM WATER. IS IT
OKAY TO ASK A QUESTION. SURE THE
AUTHORS NOT HERE OKAY- WELL I
JUST HAD A QUESTION IF THIS WAS
IT SAID- DID TO MODIFY THE
AMOUNT OF DISTILLED SPIRITS. THE
AMOUNT IS YET- OMITTING THE
OVERALL AMOUNT DISTILLERS CAN
SHIP MARC WILL GIVE YOU THAT.
YOUR LAWLER. OKAY CAN WE HAVE
THE COMMENTS AT A PRESS PUBLICLY
SALUTE BECAUSE I HAVE THE SAME
QUESTION THANK YOU ALL RIGHT. SO
THE QUESTION IS- FOR THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WHAT IS THE
AMOUNT THAT IS THE LIMIT. SO FOR
A COMMITTEE MOMENTS THE BILL
WOULD BE AMENDED FOR LARGE
DISTILLED SPIRITS SHIPPER PERMIT
HOLDERS THAT PRODUCE MORE THAN A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY GALLONS OF
DISTILLED SPIRITS PER CALENDAR
YEAR. THAT NAY IF YOU'RE UNDER
FIFTY THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND SORRY. SO FOR THOSE
LARGE DISTILLERS THE AMOUNT THAT
THEY CAN SHIP PER CALENDAR YEAR
UNDER A DIRECT SHIPPER PERMIT IS
A HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND GALLONS
. SO THEY PUT THE IT'S FOR THE
THOSE WHO. PRODUCE MORE THAN A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
GALLONS THEY CAN SHIP UP TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND GALLONS
PER YEAR RIGHT TO THE COMMITTEE
PUT A EXTRA HAIR CUT ON THE
LARGE DISTILLERS. ABOUT WHAT THE
COMMITTEES BY BUT WITH THE
AUTHORED FOR PROPOSING WITH THE
OTHER AMENDMENTS I GUESS IT.
OKAY HOLD ON THIS CONGRESS FIRST-AND I'M SORRY YOU MISTER JONES.
BUT THE LARGE DISTILLERIES ARE
STILL INCLUDED THEY ARE WITH IT
WITH A HAIR CUT AND IS IT
SILENCE ON CRAFT BEER.
DISTILLERY'S THERE NO MA'AM IT'S
RECALL MOMENTS OR RELATIVE TO
THE BEER. NO COMMITMENTS HELLO
COMMITTEE MEMONS. AND IS THE
COMMON CARRIER JUST A COMMON
CARRIER BECAUSE THERE IS A
COMMON CARRIER WITH EMPLOYEES
COMMON CARRIER. THE BEST PART OF
THE COMMITTEE AS PART OF THE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS. NUMBER OKAY
THANK YOU. OKAY MISTER JONES.
BACK ON THE LIMITS- THE LARGE
PRODUCERS HERE YOU'RE SAYING A
HUNDRED TWO THOUSAND GALLONS PER
YEAR AND INTO THE STATE BUT IS
THERE ANY IS THERE A LIMIT PER
CUSTOMER OR PER HOUSEHOLD OR-
THAT'S NOT ADDRESSED IN THE
COMMITTEE MEMBER THAT SOMETIMES
A LIMIT ON THE PERMIT HOLDER
FOR. CAN YOU SHARE IS A
SUBSCRIPTION REQUIREMENT AS YET
THEY HAVE TO HAVE A DIRECT
SHIPPER PERMIT SO IT'S UNDER
THAT PERMIT OKAY THE LIMIT IS A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND MILES-
THANK YOU AND I KNOW THAT YOU
KNOW I'M- IN MY DISTRICT I'M
HEARING FROM BOTH SIDES OF THIS
ISSUE BECAUSE I'VE GOT. YOU KNOW
SOME OF THE MAJOR CRAFT BREWERS
ARE IN MY DISTRICT AND SOME OF
THE CRAFT DISTILLERS ARE IN MY
DISTRICT AND THEN THE- THE
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION IS
HEADQUARTERED IN MY DISTRICT SO-
I KNOW THAT THE RETAILERS STILL
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BILL- I'VE BEEN TALKING TO BOTH.
THE CO AUTHORS- AND SO I THINK
WE'RE GONNA. ON A DIFFERENT
VEHICLE HELP THEM BE ON TO
SOMETHING FOR THE RETAILERS. SO
I'M GONNA SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY- AND- YOU KNOW HOPE FOR
POSITIVE CONVERSATIONS GOING
FORWARD REGARDING THE RETAILERS
WITH. OBVIOUSLY THE GEO
COMMITTEE IN THE CHAIR AND THE
AND THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. RIGHT JUST TO CLARIFY
THERE IS A REQUEST NECESSITY TO
HAVE A SUBSCRIPTION WITH THE
LARGE DISTILLERS AND THERE IS A
LIMIT- SO THOSE ARE PART OF THE
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS SELF. AND
MAKE SURE YOU HAVE THAT ATKINS
RIGHT THOUGHT OKAY. YES BUT
SHOULD BE I COULD BE CONFUSED
BUT THE AMENDMENTS NGO OR THE
ANALYSIS IN GEO ALSO SAID THAT
THIS CREATES A CRAFT DISTILLERS
LICENSE WHICH AMONG OTHER THINGS
AUTHORIZES THE LICENSEES TO
PRODUCE UP TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND GALLONS SO HOW IS THAT
DIFFERENT FROM THE LATEST
AMENDMENT. THIS AMENDMENT IS
ONLY DEALING WITH THE LARGE
DISTILLERS DOES DOES IT PRODUCE
OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
GALLONS PER YEAR IT WE BROUGHT
THEM DOWN TO MEET WITH THE-
OTHER DISTRICTS TO MEET THAT
LANGUAGE IF I UNDERSTAND
CORRECTLY. FOR THE LARGE
DISTILLERS. RIGHT BUT THIS ONE
SEEMED TO BE SILENT ON THE SIZE
OF THE DISTILLER SO I'M LIKE I
SAID THIS AMENDMENT THIS
AMENDMENT IS SPECIFIC TO THE
LARGE TO HELP RIGHT WHO WHO
PRODUCED THE OVER A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND. ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE A MOTION FOR MISTER WHAT
KOWSKI. OF MR SECRETARY HOPE
MISTER BRADFORD AS A STAND UP
I'M SORRY MISTER BRADFORD AND
USED. THE HAND. THING TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES OUR OUR TO HAVE
STILL CONCERNS ASKED YOU THE
INITIAL INTENT OF THIS BILL AND
I WAS MY UNDERSTANDING IT WAS
FOR THE SMALL CRAFT. BREWERS AND
NOW IT SEEMS LIKE YOU'RE OPENING
IT UP- NOT ONLY TO THE LARGE
FOLKS BUT ALSO ACROSS THE NATION
SHOW- I'M GETTING PUSHED IN BOTH
WAYS ON THIS THING AND I ARE
JUST STILL. NOT CLEAR ON. WHAT
WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO HELP
BECAUSE YOU STARTED OUT. OF FOR
THE SMALL GUYS AND IT SEEMS LIKE
IT'S A WILD WILD WEST
EVERYBODY'S INVITED TO PLAY
RIGHT NOW SO WHAT IS THE REAL
INTENT OF THIS MEASURE. WELL
AGAIN WE'VE HAD OUR- POLICY
DISCUSSION THE POLICY COMMITTEE
I UNDERSTAND IT IT WAS- RESTING
POLICY COMMITTEE IT WAS STATED
IT WAS GOING TO BE ADDRESSED
WHEN I GOT TO APPROACH AND I
KNOW WE'RE JUST HERE TO DO WITH
THE PHYSICAL ASPECTS OF IT BUT
I'M STILL CONCERNED ABOUT BALI
ASPECTS OF OUR ARMED. IF USED AS
TO AND I APPRECIATE YOUR CONCERN
AND AGAIN THE COMMITTEE HAS MADE
A- THEY HAD GAVE GIVEN THE LARGE
DISTILLERS A HAIR CUT TRYING TO
HIT THE SWEET SPOT SO. THE
COMMITTEE DID SO THAT'S THE ONE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONCERN. AND
THANK YOU FOR RAISING IT AND WE
HAVE A MOTION AND WE'RE GONNA
TAKE ABOUT. MISTER SECRETARY
SENATE BILL ABOUT SENATE BILL
SIX TWENTY THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
CENTER PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO
FIVE BATES BATES SB SIX TWENTY
OR HIGHER RATES ARE HIGH SENATOR
BRADFORD. BRADFORD SB SIX TWENTY
NOT VOTER. SENATOR JONES HI
JONES FIVE SENATOR KAMLAGER NOT
VOTING. SENATOR LAYERED HI
CENTER LAYERED BY SENATOR
WHITEHOUSE SKI HI CASKEY BY. WE
HAVE FIVE VOTES THAT BILL IS OUT
WITH FIVE VOTES WE'LL MOVE ON TO
SENATOR KABIRU. SHE HAS SB THREE
LOCAL CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY
PLAN THERE ARE SOME MOMENTS TO
ADD A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR. AND
WITH THAT I'LL TAKE A MOTION
MOVED BILL WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR WHITE CASKET PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATE BILL THREE
EMOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SIR PORTANTINO
HI PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES.
BATES SB THREE HI IT'S OUR
CENTER BRADFORD. BRADFORD S. B.
THREE R. RADFORD I CENTER JONES
HI JONES FIVE CENTER KAMLAGER. I
KAMLAGER EYES CENTER LAYERED
LAYER OF ICE IN A ROW CAL SKI HI
CALIFIA. SEVEN ZERO BILLS OUT
SEVEN ZERO WILL MOVE ON THE
SENATOR GLAZER SB TWENTY ONE ON
SPECIALIZED LICENSE PLATE FOR
MENTAL HEALTH AND HEALTH
AWARENESS TO MOTIONS WHEN MADE
WILL BE TO DO PASSED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR SO MOVED. A MOTION
BY SENATOR WHITE CASKET PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATE BILL
TWENTY ONE MOTIONS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO HÌNH PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES. BATES SB TWENTY
ONE HI BATES FAR CENTER BRADFORD
. BRADFORD SB TWENTY ONE ARE
BRADFORD DODD SENATOR JONES
JONES FIVE CENTER KAMLAGER I AM
LONGER I CENTER LAYERED HI LARRY
I CENTER MY COUNTY HI KELSEY I
MORE SEVEN ZERO CAPITALISM SEVEN
ZERO MOVING ON TO SENATOR
HERTZBERG SB FIVE THIRTEEN ON
HOMELESS SHELTER GRANTS FOR PETS
AND VETERINARY SERVICES. THE
MOTION WHEN MADE WILL BE TO PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR THE MOVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR WHAT KASKY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATE
BILL FIVE ONE THREE MOTIONS TO
PASS THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES. SB FIVE THIRTEEN
NINE. DAYS BATES SB. THIRTY FIVE
THIRTEEN NINE. ABOUT BATES AYE
CENTER BRADFORD BRADFORD SP FIVE
ONE THREE. BRADFORD AYE SENATOR
JONES I JONES I CENTER KAMLAGER.
KAMLAGER BY SENATOR LAYERED
LAYERED BY SENATOR MCCASKEY HI
KELSEY ARE. LOTUS OF ZERO
ABILITY SEVEN ZERO MOVE ON THE
SAN MAN TO EIGHTHS. ONE ORANGE
BOARD OF EDUCATION ALEXION'S OF
THE MOTION WHEN MADE WILL BE TO
DO PASSED TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
SOME OF WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR Y. CASKEY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATE BILL TWO EIGHT
SIX THE MOTIONS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO
HI PORTANTINO AYE CENTER BATES.
BATES S. B. TWO EIGHTY SIX NO.
NO SENATOR BRADFORD BRADFORD SB
TWO EIGHT SIX R. RADFORD BY
SENATOR JONES JONES NO CENTER
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER EYES CENTER
LAYERS LAYERED SENATOR WHAT
COUNTY CASKEY A VOTED FOR TO TWO
THE BILL OUT WITH VOTES MOVING
ON TO. SENATOR PER- SB FORTY
FIVE ON. SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANT LOCAL SAYS THE MOTION
WHEN MADE WILL BE TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR SO MOVED HAVE A
MOTION MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SENATE BILL FORTY FIVE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES.
BATES SB FORTY FIVE I'D- HI
SENATOR BRADFORD EFFORT S. B.
FOUR FIVE HI. RADFORD SENATOR
JONES HI JONES FIVE CENTER
KAMLAGER I AM ORDER I'D SENATOR
LAYERED ALL RIGHT WHERE ARE
CENTER WORKOUTS SKI HI KELSEY
FIVE BILL SEVEN ZERO. THE BILL
WAS OUT SEVEN ZERO PORTANTINO S.
B. TWO THIRTY CONSTITUENTS OF
EMERGING CONCERN DRINKING WATER
PROGRAM THE MOTION WILL BE WITH-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO MAKE THE
BILL CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION SO MOVED A MOTION
BY SENATOR Y. CASKEY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATOR PORTANTINO'S
S. B. TWO THIRTY THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR CENTER PORTANTINO AYE
PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES.
BATES S. B. TWO THIRTY HI.
BETTER BATES FIVE CENTER
BRADFORD. BRADFORD SB TWO THREE
ZERO ARE UNDER BRADFORD BY
CENTER JONES BY JONES FIVE
CENTER KAMLAGER I AM WATER ICE
SENATOR LAYERED. I SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE HI CASKEY I THE BILL HAS
SEVEN LOOKS OF THOSE OUT THERE
WILL GO TO SB THREE EIGHTY SEVEN
PORTANTINO SCHOOL EMPLOYEE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH TRAINING. IS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION SO MOVED
A MOTION BY SENATOR Y. CASKEY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATE BILL
THREE EIGHT SEVEN THE MOTIONS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR CENTER
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO AYE
BATES. EIGHT SB THREE SEVEN HI.
BATES III CENTER BRADFORD
BRADFORD SB THREE EIGHT SEVEN R.
BRADFORD DODD SENATOR JONES HI
JONES I CENTER KAMLAGER I AM
LONGER BY SENATOR LAYERED
LAYERED BY SENATOR WORKOUTS SKI
HI CASKEY ARE. SEVEN ZERO A BILL
OUTSIDE ZERO ON AS BEFORE EIGHTY
FIVE FILM TAX CREDIT EXTENSION
IS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION. SO
MOVED A MOTION BY SENATOR WHAT
KASKY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS THAT THE MEASURE
RETURN BE RETURNED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR FOR CONSIDERATION. SIR
PORTANTINO. I BY SENATOR BATES
BATES SB FOUR EIGHTY FIVE HI
EIGHT FIVE SENATOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD SB FOUR EIGHT FIVE ARE
BRADFORD ALIGNCENTER JONES I.
JONES FIVE CENTER KAMLAGER. HI
KAMLAGER EYES SENATOR LAYER.
AIRED ON ICE AND WHAT CUSK BY
KELSEY I SIMPLE SEVEN ZERO THOSE
OUT SEVEN ZERO MOVING ON TO
SENATOR SKINNER SB THREE OH ONE
ONLINE MARKETPLACE IT IS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION. SO MOVED. I
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR Y.
CASKEY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATE BILL THREE ZERO ONE
MOTIONS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO BY SENATOR BATES
BATES SB THREE OH ONE HI BATES
AYE SENATOR BRADFORD BRADFORD SB
THREE A ONE DOLLAR BRADFORD FIVE
SENATOR JONES I JONES FIVE
SENATOR KAMLAGER I AM HONORED BY
SENATOR LAYERED ALL RIGHT
LAYERED I SENATOR MURKOWSKI HIGH
KELSEY R. FORTY SEVEN ZERO. THE
BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO SKINNER
SB THREE SIX FOUR ON CHILD
NUTRITION FREE MEALS- THERE ARE
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE THE PROGRAM
CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATIONS.
SO MOVED. WE HAVE A MOTION SENT
WHITE HOUSE PLEASE THE ROLL
SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES. BATES SB THREE
SIXTY FOUR I. BATES BATES IS
SENATOR BRADFORD BRADFORD SB
THREE SIX FOUR OUR BRADFORD AYE
SENATOR JONES. JONES I CENTER
KAMLAGER. I KAMLAGER I SENATOR
LAYERED ARE LAYERED I SENATOR
MURKOWSKI HI LCI VOTERS SEVEN
ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT SEVEN THIS
YEAR MOVING ON SB SIX FORTY ONE
CALFRESH COLLEGE STUDENT ACT
THAT MOTION IS WITH AMENDMENTS
TO REMOVE THE DATA COLLECTION
REQUIREMENT AND ADD SPECIFIED
SPECIFIED REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
SO MOVED. A MOTION BY SENATOR
WHAT KASKY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATE BILL SIX FORTY ONE THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SENATE SENATOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES. BATES SB SIX
FORTY ONE HI BATES I CENTER
BRADFORD. BRADFORD SB SIX FOR
ONE OF OUR BRADFORD BY SENATOR
JONES ACT JONES I SENATOR
KAMLAGER I AM LONGER SENATORS.
HI LATER DYSON RECKONS HI
CASCADE. FORTY SEVEN ZERO.
HABILIS OUTS ZERO MOVING ON TO
SENATOR WIENER SB TWO SIX OH ON
CLIMATE CORPORATE ACCOUNTABILITY
THE MOTION IS. TO PASS THE MOVE
. I HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR WHY%
CASKET CALL THE ROLL. SB TWO
SIXTY MOTIONS TO PASS A SENATE
FOR CENTER. HI PORTANTINO EYES
BATES. BATES S. B. TWO SIXTY NO.
BATES NO SENATOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD SB TWO SIX ZERO OUR
BRADFORD DODD SENATOR JONES
HELLO JONES KNOWS CENTER
KAMLAGER. I AM HONORED BY
SENATOR LAYERED. LAYERED BY
SENATOR MAKOWSKI HI CAL SKEOCH
VOTERS FIVE TO TWO. THE BILL HAS
FIVE TO MOVING ON SB THREE
SEVENTY NINE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PERMITTING
RESIDENTIAL SOLAR FACILITIES.
MOTIONS TO PASS SOME OF MOTION
BY MISTER WHAT KOWSKI PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATE BILL THREE
SEVENTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
SENATOR BATES. BATES SB THREE
SEVEN NINE NOT VOTING. SENATE
BRADFORD. SB THREE SEVEN NINE
OUR BRADFORD BY SENATOR JONES
UPLOADING. SENATOR KAMLAGER.
KAMLAGER EYES SENATOR LAYERED
LAYERED BY SENATOR AKOWSKI HI
CASKEY I VOTE IS FIVE TWO ZERO
THE BILL IS OUT FIVE ZERO WILL
MOVE ON SB FOUR SIX SEVEN TRIAL
TESTIMONY EXPERT WITNESSES THEIR
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO MAKE A
CLARIFYING CHANGE AND AT A CO
AUTHOR. SO MOVED. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SENATOR FOR SIX SENATE
BILL FOR SIXTY SEVEN THE MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR SENATOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE SENATOR BATES.
BATES S. B. FOUR SIX SEVEN I'D-
BATES AYE SENATOR BRADFORD.
BRADFORD SB FOUR SIX SEVEN ARE
BRADFORD DODD SENATOR JONES.
JONES FIVE SENATOR KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER BY SENATOR LAYERED
CENTER LAYERED ICE SENATOR
MCKENZIE HI CAL I SPOKE SEVEN
ZERO AFTER WAS OUT SEVEN ZERO WE
HAVE NO BILLS ON CALL THAT
CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS AND
AGAIN- FOLLOWING THE HEARING-
RESULT IN ACTIONS ARE TAKEN EACH
MEASURE WILL BE POSTED ON THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WEBSITE WHICH IS AGAIN W. W. W.
DOT S. A. P. R. DOT SENATE DOT
CA DOT GOV AND ANY AMENDED
ANALYSIS WILL ALSO BE AVAILABLE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
THIS MORNING THAT CONCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED ALL.